vom hotel zum burger battle durch
münchen irgendwie ich die pampa und
nötig aber so ein roller vor ort man
locker dieselstraße müde oder schlafen
ganze gefrühstückt gehabt pancakes media
und sirup und bewahren sie müssen sogar
extra aufgestanden um 7 uhr um den
schützen dann schwimmen kann tatsächlich
aber jetzt geht es erstmal ziemlich
donalds und sehen uns beim mails wieder
sind am stehst hier jung klar es war der
rock es war die krippe seelöwe macdonald
cordes oderberg alcoa lasse sich jetzt
noch ein und ging dann irgendwas gezeigt
keine ahnung wenn ich versuche mich ist
es erst daraus let's play pokerstars 11
es war deshalb haben wir unsere sachen
abgelegt da draußen ist die ganze
veranstaltung und hier guck mal hier
da seht ihr hier präsent für baden
württemberg daraus verhalten so mache
ich meinen kleinen abstecher in die
küche das gelb zeigen darf undercover
ein probekochen zum ersten mal zusammen
jetzt machen wir noch kurz fotos da gibt
es noch ein kleines fotoshooting
im film wieder aufgenommen
kerner gut beleuchtete super mann den
wir schon die fotos gemacht haben ist
eine kleine filmaufnahme und wenn noch
mal fotos aufgenommen also volles
programm solo der besitz gerade in der
besprechung das ist der essen sind es in
der nahaufnahme rasse pixel
dahinten unsere zwei juroren und coaches
die uns gerade ein bisschen ausgeholfen
haben sie zumindest mal genießt bauhaus
und da draußen so liebe leute jetzt
gerade hier draußen mit der marke 6
gerade angekommen ich gehe gleich noch
weiter zum test kocher und da darf ich
zum einen burger probieren und dann
entscheidet sich auch schon eine
präsentation 60 sekunden
oder man vorkochen die thüringer firma
entscheiden und dann wird sich zeigen ob
der essen sind ist das ding gewinnt oder
nicht
wir sind jetzt hier in der küche ich
habe schon die schürze an und wir
bereiten jetzt hier den passenden
diskussion kommen ebenfalls und ich
hoffe dass es ihm geschmeckt ich das
essen schmeckt reguliert ist vorgesehen
ich hoffe ich hoffe das dings max jetzt
geht es an die arbeit
die zutaten sind präpariert und ich
übergebe die kamera
das folgendermaßen zu drehen und vom
deckel abwerzger anfang an mit der bahn
zu sehen
aufnahmen
auf den zehnten platz in der mannschaft
sagte schöne
lehmann
tomaten spezialzug mit wirkung vom 1
partie drauf und 2020 um die krise quasi
inzwischen dement ist für mich eine
chance in der 2
seine maschine blieb
sowohl der groß
damit seien
wir haben noch mal den vergleich der
essen sie das beste richtig geil mit
roten ziegeln erweitert und dahinter
einfach ganz egal was mich jetzt
überhaupt für ein name
die paarung steht fest und zwar hier die
nummer fünf
das gegen den kapitän vertreten
amerikaner hier endeffekt gewinnen
er fing in der erste runde raus leute so
wie immer der hat einfach diesen krieg
gerade darin dass let's play pokal etwa
o2 und jetzt will beim burger battles
dritte meine ersten runde rausfliegen
doch ganz gut
ok
zuerst auf jeder dass ich hier sein darf
da für mich jetzt auf den namen gegen
essen das tier hatte er das ist
verwirrung gesorgt
in antwort
machen
so ist die entscheidung hier entscheidet
sich ob man gewinnt oder der figaro
essen
leute jetzt entscheidet sich jetzt
entscheidet sich sie sind unter den
besten sieben
wenn jetzt haben wir die gelegenheit
noch unter die besten vier zu kommen und
dann kommt der bürger die läden für
wochen sehr sehr geil
lukas die chance heute
der mac michels und der essen sieht
dessen beide noch drin
wenn das die entscheidung
nächstes passieren
ich bin
wissen sie was ich esse ich es
ich weiß dass gegen die st
mega geil auf jeden fall vielen dank
und ich hoffe bei den bürgern die laden
kopf neben den drogen zu herzen
junge wir sind die ganze zeit am suche
nach diesem scheiß fluss und hier isa
macht durch bitte dich um ich hätte es
so weit da jetzt nichts gefunden wo man
im wir einspringen kann
deswegen so dass wir auch echt verrückt
wenn wir das hier zieht sich ja jetzt
schon diesen stock in meiner hand einer
homo locker sterbe ich jetzt die wende
ist dass ich noch versucht mit dem kopf
unter wasser zu gehen
ein dicker gehirn wächst in spanien
shops für dich wegreißen weg gerückt
okay leute also ich hab's gemacht
essen 11 grad dieser hat wahrscheinlich
7 und ja ich war drin lacht nein macht
nicht nachkommt ist auch so ein bogen da
kann man nicht rein springen davon
praktisch keine chance
dumme wette also macht man sich noch mal
hieß